VAIBHAV GOVIL: Hi, my
name is Vaibhav Govil.
I'm a product manager
and Cloud Spanner.
Today I'm going to talk about
how customers are future
proofing their business for
global scale and consistency
with Cloud Spanner.
So as part of this
talk I'm going
to cover three main areas.
First and foremost, I'm going to
introduce you to Cloud Spanner.
Second, we are seeing
a lot of momentum
with Cloud Spanner
for our customers.
And I'm going to talk
about what customers
are using Cloud Spanner,
which verticals,
and what other use cases.
And last, I'm going to share
some recent developments which
we have done in Cloud Spanner.
New features, new capabilities,
which are up and coming.
So we'll talk about that.
So to get to it Cloud
Spanner is a unique database.
Basically, Cloud Spanner
offers horizontal scalability
with complete
relational semantics.
Horizontal scale
is something which
you would expect from
non-relational databases, which
are sharded and everything.
Spanner does all that, in
addition to offering you
asset transactions,
complete sequence support,
all the relational
semantics which you expect
from a relational database.
To top it off it's
highly available,
means we are talking about
five-nines of availability
in a multi-regional
configuration.
It's fully managed.
And this is something which
Google built for itself.
A number of our billion
plus user products
are sitting on top of Spanner.
They use Spanner as
the main database.
And it's something
which we have been
using for quite a long time.
Now how do we make it work?
What are the key building
blocks for Spanner?
So there are three
main elements to it.
First and foremost, it's
the Google's network.
So Spanner is synchronously
replicated behind the scenes.
So network plays a
large role as part
of what we offer to our
customers in terms of latency,
in terms of reliability.
And having Google's network
infrastructure backing Cloud
Spanner is really important.
And as you know Google's
network infrastructure
is redundant highly available.
And Spanner being
multi-regional and something
which our customers are using
as a global database network
plays a big role.
Second is True Time.
So the picture on the right
of the screen as you can see,
they are atomic oscillators
and GPS antennas.
This is actually
a picture for one
of our servers in
our data centers.
And basically what
it's showing you is we
have atomic and GPD
clocks in our data center.
And what it offers
is to our customers,
this gives a global
notion of time for Spanner
to function on.
So once there is a global
notion of time for a distributed
database we can promise
external strong consistency
to our customers.
And this is something which
is extremely important,
the ordering of transactions
for financial services,
for retail sector.
And that is something
which we are only
able to offer
because of True Time.
And last night but not least, we
have a very optimized software
stack with a custom
Paxos implementation,
automatic resharding based
on load and size of data.
All the magic which
makes Spanner work.
So now naturally a
question needs to be asked,
why Cloud Spanner?
What is that's so
different in comparison
to a relational database?
First and foremost, as I
already talked about earlier,
it's scale.
And the scale insurance
which our customers get out
of Spanner with
high availability.
So in terms of scale there
is literally no limit.
And you can start small
and seamlessly scale.
That is very
important for a number
of use cases, which we'll
talk about in the later part
of the presentation.
Second, multi-region with
transparent synchronous
replication.
We are talking about
a one click experience
in setting up a global instance
across multiple continents.
Strong external
consistency, which I already
discussed about.
Pretty much as one walks the
relational database experience
you can get from a horizontally
scalable Cloud Spanner
database.
There's no concept of
planned maintenance windows.
And that's why we
are able to offer you
such high availability.
It's completely managed, you
can all also do completely
online schema changes.
You don't have to take
a down time for that.
We have complete separation
of storage and compute.
This becomes extremely
important for scalability.
So you can seamlessly scale
your workload because there's
no coupling between
storage and compute,
and you can scale
them independently.
We launch manage backups, I'm
going to talk a little bit more
in detail about it, but
there are consistent backups.
We also offer cell level
concurrency control
which is extremely important for
a database like Spanner which
has use cases where
customers are wishing
and millions of QPS.
And cell level concurrency
control really helps.
And again, we have databases
internally which have
which are petabytes plus
size for a single database.
So scale both on the QPS side
as well as the storage side.
So this is just a
representation of some
of the key feature highlights.
Again, I'm not going to
talk about each one of them.
But these are the
different categories
where we continue to
innovate and offer
more features and
capabilities to our customers.
First and foremost,
it's the enterprise
and relational capabilities.
So I talked about fine
grained concurrency control,
manage backups, we
have secondary indexes.
On the programmability
side, we continue
to add more client drivers.
We have eight
which are now in G.
We have complete DDL
and DMLs onboarding,
including Batch DML.
We have commit timestamps,
which customers are using it
for multiple use cases,
foreign keys which
was recently launched.
Local Emulator, we'll
talk a lot about some
of these capabilities
later on as well.
And then on the security side
we launched VPC Service Control,
Access Transparency.
All the data by default is
encrypted-at-rest, that's
something which we offer.
So a lot of capabilities
which customers
expect from enterprise database
from a security standpoint.
And which not just Spanner, but
GCP overall is very good at.
In terms of monitoring
and introspection
we have a lot of
capabilities which
we continue to offer with more
so we can provide more of you
into what your
workload is doing.
We have open cenus integration,
CPU utilization graph,
latency graphs, a
number of those things.
So moving on, now
I talked about what
is Cloud Spanner, what are some
of the key capabilities which
it offers.
I think it's important to
understand why customers
are choosing Cloud Spanner.
And for that it's
important to know
what are some of the challenges
which customers face today.
And how Spanner kind of plays
a role in terms of alleviating
some of those challenges.
So first and foremost, there
are these business challenges
for customers.
For example, the first
one is the capital expense
which they have to take for
some seasonal peak workloads.
So let's say you
are a retailer, you
are planning for your couple
of days of Black Friday,
Cyber Monday sale.
And to pay for all that
fixed infrastructure
for just those couple of days
where you might experience
1,000% scaling is quite a bit.
So that is something which goes
on on the books and something
we are concerned about.
Then the second thing
is, all our customers,
majority of them, they
have global customer base
of their own.
They want to provide a great
experience to their customers
so they have to invest in
multi-regional presence, which
is again not cheap.
And last but not least is
the operational expense,
which is exacerbated by
some of the seasonal scaling
which comes with the workloads.
So you have to plan for that
operation and maintenance
and everything.
So all this ties
into the expense,
but there is a human element
to it as well because
of operations and maintenance.
On the technical side a number
of customers we work with
are very concerned
about high availability.
In today's day and age, if
you are serving your traffic
at the peak time, whether
it's health care for health
care, its enrollment
season, for retailers
it's some of those big days,
and for financial services
any other times when a lot
of payments are being made.
High business continuity
is needed, so how
do you plan for that with
appropriate DR capabilities.
There should be
absolutely no downtime.
It should be able
to scale seamlessly
based on the workload.
Consistency is
extremely important.
For example, if you are
doing a debit and credit
in financial application
it's extremely important
that the ordering of
those transactions
is maintained by the database
as part of when it was done.
And if you go back and
take a look that order
should remain the same.
And again, the global
nature of the world which
we live in from a customer
base perspective, everybody
wants to serve their
customers with low latency,
and they need a consistent
view of data globally.
And last but not least, the
solution which they have
needs to integrate
with multiple systems.
And whether a database
provides those hooks.
So based on the
critical capabilities
which we discussed
earlier, Spanner
fits the bill in all of this,
and meets the requirements
which customers come to us.
So as a nation we are seeing
a lot of momentum on Spanner
across multiple verticals.
Some of them are listed here.
And if we think from basically
the differentiators of Spanner,
which is extreme scaling,
higher availability,
strong consistency of
data, and ease of use,
it's really easy to
understand why all these use
cases are coming to Spanner.
Across gaming, financial
services, health care,
media entertainment, technology,
a lot of technology companies
are coming and adopting
Spanner in retail.
So let's just picking up on
now from the gaming side,
if you are a game developer,
and you are making
a game you like to start small.
And once the game makes it big
or you are the next Pokemon Go,
then you don't have
time to re-architect
the app for that scale.
So Spanner allows you
to do exactly that.
That you can start small
with the right schema,
and then you can
seamlessly scale
from hundreds to thousands
to millions of queries
per second in transactions.
And for data size
which can be similarly
like in megabytes,
GBs or even petabytes.
And a lot of
customers are using it
to store user profile,
real time gameplay data,
and a lot of those
applications are there.
Similarly, on
financial services,
extreme high availability,
external consistency,
all those.
And definitely ability to
scale is extremely important.
And that's why a
number of banks are now
switching to Spanner for the
online banking and ledger use
cases.
Health care, we have a number
of big health care customers
who are implementing
the complete EMR
systems on Spanner, which
is extremely exciting for us
to see the health care space.
With all the compliance, HIPAA,
PCI, we are in compliance,
we offer that kind of
compliance to our customers.
So as long as it's
implemented correctly,
so health care and across a lot
of these regulatory industries
we are seeing a lot of
adoption, detailed technology.
So as a next step,
I'm not going to dive
into each of these use cases,
but just pick a couple of them
and discuss them in detail.
So first off, on this
is financial services
retail banking use case.
This slide presents the complete
solution architecture for it.
So as you can see,
basically the use cases
there's this
traditional retail bank
which has migrated to Spanner.
In this day in age they
have omni-channel way
for their customers to access
the same financial data
and transact with that
through mobile, through web,
through voice, and
even third party.
And this is basically just
shown at the top of the slide.
And then Spanner
piece is right there
in this red rectangle which is
the operation of database side.
And this is a very common
architectural pattern
which we have seen where a
Spanner connects with GKE.
And so it can seamlessly scale
both from the client side,
as well as on the database side.
So it's a very typical pattern.
And then as I was
mentioning earlier
it's extremely important
that the database
can hook up with the legacy
systems or other systems which
are there.
For example, the other
core banking systems
which are there or
payment gateways
as is shown at the bottom.
And then as the data
is getting updated
in the OLTP database,
which is Spanner,
the data almost
in near real time
is getting populated
in analytics
and warehousing
solutions as well.
So the customer is able to
do that [INAUDIBLE] queries
and generate insights from that.
That is within BigQuery
and Cloud AI data
catalog and everything.
So that whole chain is set up
using Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
And on the security
and governance side,
we offer all kinds
of integration,
like Cloud Monitoring
DLP and customers
are able to benefit with
that across the board.
So this is just one of
those solution architectures
where Spanner plays that
operational database role
and is able to
seamlessly scale along
with the rest of the
architecture, which
is extremely critical
for our customers.
Next I'm not talking about the
complete retail omni-channel
retail architecture
for this customer,
but just focusing on
the Spanner piece.
So in this case the use case
was the omni-channel retail
customer is getting
updated prices delivered
to GCP through an
external system,
both as a streaming
data pipeline
as well as in batches the
data was being uploaded.
And then Spanenr
was the database
of record for all the SKUs
with the updated prices.
And then Spanner is
serving those prices
to all the applications which
this omni-channel retailer is
running.
So as you can see from
the solution architecture
that the prices are being
uploaded in cloud storage.
And then through load service
running as part of Kubernetes
is being uploaded
into Cloud Spanner.
And then Cloud Spanner is
just serving all the requests
from the pricing API standpoint.
Again, in this case
Spanner is getting
a lot of write load
as well as read load.
And depending on
the traffic it's
able to scale up based on
the needs of the application
and the [INAUDIBLE]
and everything.
So again, very important.
And in this case
that we're using
a multi-regional instance,
so five-nines of availability
with global presence
and everything.
So extremely happy with
the way it turned out
and the customer is really
very happy with the solution.
So switching gears now,
let's talk about what's
new in Cloud Spanner.
And just a reflection of
the past a little bit.
So we had a busy 2019.
We delivered capabilities
and three of--
in all areas basically.
We have categorized in these
three major areas, enterprise
capabilities developer
productivity, and SQL.
So on the enterprise
side I already talked
about VPC access
transparency, which
is extremely critical for some
of our regulatory industry
users.
Where when even
Google S.R.D. when
they touched your data for any
reason, that kind of an action
has to be locked.
So that is access transparency.
Spanner supports
access transparency.
And we updated our SLA
in September, 2019.
Basically now all your
Cloud Spanner instances,
even with a single
node, are powered
under the same production SLA.
So this way even for
smaller workloads
you are protected by the
same SLA which we offer.
Before September, 2019 we used
to require a minimum three
nodes in an instance.
And the reason we were
able to update our SLA
is because Spanner behind
the scenes is replicated.
So even in case of
a regional instance
there are three replicas.
And we are able to offer
you that high availability
with a single node.
And multi-region has
multiple replicas,
like five, seven, and nine
replica configurations is
something which we offer today.
On the developer
productivity side,
we continue to invest in ORMs.
We have launched a new
initiative and something
which is getting a lot of
momentum called Cloud Spanner
Ecosystem.
The website is actually
cloudspannerecosystem.dev
or DEV.
And because as you
noticed, we have
a lot of momentum with Spanner.
A number of customers
are contributing tools
in the ecosystem for
other Spanner users.
And we have a lot of
partners contributing tools
and Google is as well.
So we created this
ecosystem as a single place
where they can make
their contributions
for the benefit of
the overall community,
and we are seeing
a lot of traction.
Please check it out.
There are a number
of tools which
are available for our users.
And last but not the
least on the SQL side, we
continue to innovate for
the query optimizer relaunch
cost based index selection as
part of the query optimization.
We have Batch DML support,
we launch WITH clause.
Again, trying to offer
all the capabilities which
you expect from a database
from the SQL side.
We had a fairly busy 2020 so far
again in all those three areas
we continue to make improvements
and launch new capabilities.
And manage
backup-restore, I'm not
going to spend too
much time here.
I'll go into details later.
We continue to expand on our
multi-regional configuration
options.
We originally had four
multi-regional instance
configurations.
We recently launched two new
multi-regional configurations.
One in Asia only, [INAUDIBLE]
and another one in Europe.
And then we recently launched
a change watcher solution,
which is not a native
capability but a solution, which
is built on top of Spanner
leveraging the current times
feature, where
customers can watch out
for changes which are happening
within their database.
And on the developer
productivity side
we-- a emulator is something,
this is an offline emulator.
I'm going to talk
more in details later.
But C++ Client library,
Transaction Statistics,
and Harbor Bridge which is
another tool which was recently
contributed in Cloud
Spanner Ecosystem.
It is to aid in migration.
It actually, the
capability it provides
is if a customer has
a PostgreSQL schema
and they use Harbor
Bridge, the tool
can recommend an equal
Spanner schema with it.
So originally we launched
it for PostgreSQL support,
and for MySQL we have
launched it in beta right now.
And on the SQL side Query
Optimizer Versioning,
I talk more in details on
that later, and Foreign Keys.
So I'm not going
to go into details
of each one of
these capabilities,
but I'll pick one from
each of these areas
and tell you a little
bit more about them.
So first and foremost
is managed backups,
which we launched with
general availability in April.
So this is on demand
managed backups.
This is primarily to offer
protection to our customers
against operator
application errors which can
cause logical data corruption.
So what we offer is
consistent backup
for regional and
multi-regional instances.
And what we are optimizing
for is extremely fast restores
or time to first-byte access.
Because if you run
into an issue you
would like to get back
online with your application
as soon as possible,
and we recognize that.
So even for a backup,
which is terabytes in size,
you can expect to
get first-byte access
as part of your restore
process within minutes.
So that is something which
we have really optimized for.
You can restore from your
backup within the same instance
configuration or basically
within the same instance
or another instance within the
same instance configuration.
And the maximum retention
time for backups is one year.
And from a security
perspective, we
are IM access permissions
are separate for backup.
So customers have
the flexibility
to create a separate role
just to manage the backups
and do the restores.
So that is there.
And again, the feature is
available through API, Console,
gCloud.
Local Emulator, so
this is something which
we announced in beta in March.
I'm happy to announce the
general availability of Local
Emulator as part of this talk.
So this is now
generally available.
We have implemented a
lot more capabilities
as part of this general
available launch for Local
Emulator.
It is an offline open
source local emulator.
The code is open,
you can take a look.
It's in our GitHub repository.
It offers complete REST
and gRPC API support.
And it offers SQL, basically
DML and DDL support.
Most importantly, it
has complete support
for information schema as well.
Now, all client
libraries are supported
for working with Emulator.
And this really, we
have got great feedback
from a number of our customers.
And it has really helped them
from productivity, developer
productivity perspective,
because now they
can do a very quick correctness
testing for their application
in an offline environment.
And last but not the
least, Cloud Spanner
offered Query Optimizer
Versioning capability
to our customers.
And this is a GA feature.
So basically what does it mean?
Now users have the flexibility
to run their queries
with a specific version
of Query Optimizer.
There's a range of
choices which we offer.
You can pin your
complete database
on a query optimize
version, or you
can decide to pin
just your application
on a specific query optimizer
version with the default query
optimizer for the database
as being something different.
So you can override the
default on the database.
And finally, you can use
a specific query optimizer
origin as a query hint as well.
And you can test your query
with a specific query optimizer
version.
So there's a range of
choices and flexibility
which we offer as
part of this feature.
And customers can decide
to pin their application
the whole database and get that
same predictable performance
from Spanner.
So that concludes my
presentation, but as next steps
we have a couple of very
interesting talks planned
for Spanner.
First, we have our talk
which one of our customers
is going to give about switching
from DynamoDB to Cloud Bigtable
and Spanner.
Please tune into that.
It was a fairly big undertaking
in terms of migration
from Dynamo.
You're talking terabytes
of data and a lot
of throughput in
that application
was then migrated from Dynamo
onto Spanner and Bigtable.
And then there's
another talk, which
one of our gaming specialists
is giving about how customers
can modernizing and
modernize their gaming
applications with Spanner.
Again to benefit from the
scale and consistency which
Spanner offers.
There's also a showcase
demo which has been planned,
and there's a quick lab.
We welcome you to try it out
and learn more about Spanner
through that.
With that, thanks a lot.
Thanks for your
time and attention.
I really appreciate it.
And thanks for using Spanner.
And please reach out to us
if you have any questions.
Thank you.